hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar a crispr powered ngs library
prep to improve viral bacterial and host
transcript detection in shotgun
metagenomic sequencing
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by jump code genomics to learn more
visit jumpcodegenomics.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker john
armstrong vice president of research and
development jump code genomics
john you may now begin your presentation
hello my name is john armstrong i'm the
vp of r d at jump code genomics and
today i'm going to be telling you about
a crispr powered ngs library prep which
improves viral bacterial and host
transcription detection in shotgun
metagenomic sequencing
next generation sequencing has evolved
into a powerful tool for genomic
discovery and it's lowered the cost and
increased throughput unfortunately much
of that sequencing power spent decoding
biologically uninformative sequences
so refining ngs libraries by removing
those sequences refocuses that power of
the sequencing on biologically relevant
content and this can lead to greater
insights and identification of novel
transcripts or variants
so total rna library prep and ribosomal
depletion is completed through seven
steps and is less than a day
crispr clean depletion is performed
after adapter ligation the crispr cas9
complexes are formed with a pool of
designed guide rnas and the complexes
are mixed with the adapter ligated cdna
library
after the unwanted sequences are cut
they cannot be substrates for pcr
amplification and sequencing and this
the result is a refined ngs library
this approach can be used across a
number of applications you see at the
bottom of slide and today i'll show data
on several of these applications with
the focus on infectious disease
surveillance
so you can see here a blown up schematic
of the of the digestion section of the
protocol we essentially have adapter
ligated molecules we can then use crispr
as a molecular scissor to cut those
molecules up any molecule that's not
contiguous does not go through the pcr
process and thus have following pcr
amplification and cleanup we have a
refined ngs library
so this next section of data that i'm
going to show focuses on the removal of
ribosomal rna from bulk rna libraries
and it employs jump codes full solution
which is our library prep and depletion
kit
the data shows it basically shows the
tech works that's why i'm showing it to
you but ultimately it sets the stage for
further development around infectious
disease detection
on the left we're showing the depletion
of ribosomal content using
crispr clean
from
human mouse rat
cow dog and chicken we used
control
total rna from those
organisms to apply our depletion
technology and you can see although the
percentage of ribosomal rna differs in
the
mock or untreated sample
we are
highly or heavily removing the ribosomal
rna from these samples down to five
percent or less
on the right side the graph on the right
you can see that if we if we calculate
the rate of ribosomal depletion which is
simply the
percentage of mach in the sample minus
the percentage of depleted ribosomal
divided by the mock you can see here
that we have greater than 90 ribosomal
rna depletion across these organisms
next we took universal human reference
total rna
and we used it as an input to our
library and depletion kit at uh
increasing amounts so we went from one
nanogram to 100 nanograms and then with
the resulting sequencing data are able
to calculate the number of genes on the
y-axis that we see it at one read count
or 10 read counts or greater and you can
see here that the
that the number of genes discovered is
very high
for each of the inputs and is also
comparable showing that the the method
and platform that we're using here with
crispr depletion is uh is consistent and
robust across this input range
in those uhr libraries that i just or
sorry the uhr samples that i just showed
we spiked in ercc controls
at each of those inputs i'm only showing
on the left side here the 5 nanogram
input and 100 nanogram input but what
we're able to do is to look at the
the counts for the ercc controls
in a depleted library
versus an undepleted library to
understand uh to what extent the method
of the crispr clean technology to what
extent that injects noise into the
system and you can see here that when
comparing the counts between a depleted
library and an undepleted library of
five nanogram input a very high r
squared and strong linearity of signal
across the ercc's this is showing
consistency here
and very little technical noise or
method noise being injected into the
system and also we see that same
linearity hold at 100 nanograms of input
as well
with a a depleted and an undepleted
library
on the right side the graph here
we're looking here at the
at the gene counts not the ercc counts
but the gene counts of the of the human
genes and the uhr sample for a hundred
nanograms of rna input on the y-axis and
five nanograms of rna and put on the
x-axis and you can see here
that the uh that the
linearity holds true for human genes as
well with an r-squared of 0.99
on this slide we're showing the results
of looking at full change
of human gene expression which helps to
quantify noise and here we're looking at
the full change between
human gene expression at five nanograms
and 100 nanogram library input
the expectation is that uh the signal
should line up across the zero line if
there is no fold change between the two
different inputs and as you can see here
that
expectation is met showing total input
rna has little to no effect on noise
so as i mentioned in the previous slides
the platform slides for the technology
and our full solution
you know i covered the percentage and
rate of depletion across different
organisms as well as the stability of
ercc spike ins at different inputs and
finally the
consistency of human gene expression
across different inputs as well
now that i've shown that data i want to
move on to show the in vitro use of the
crispr cast system and how it improves
detection sensitivity of metagenomics in
gs
before i show any data i first want to
show the study design we employed
we used coveted samples for the study
design of course the coveted genome is
serving as a proxy for any infectious
disease here but coveted samples are
relatively easy to get a hold of right
now
we use 60 nasopharyngeal samples 45
covet positive
ranging in cycle threshold values from
rt pcr from 16 to 39
and we had 15 covet negative samples
each one of these was split into three
where one consisting of one control and
two replicas for depletion each one of
these then went through sequencing
library construction and depletion
so we had 180 samples
there
moved into sequencing sequencing at 2 by
150 bases
and then down sampling the data to 80
million reads or 40 million clusters
we then employed a five-prong analysis
approach using idc for pathogen
detection sars genome assembly niad
priority pathogen assessment and g said
clade identif identity uh for the
genomes
we star for alignments and gatk for
variant calling
kraken 2
we used as a k-mer-based
system for interrogating the composition
of the samples
a pipeline called dgnr for differential
expression for host response and then
also custom in-house pipelines for
computing depletion rates
where we use the silva database which is
a compendium of all known ribosomal rna
sequences
i'm going to show data from each of
these analysis today
i'm showing the performance of the chris
crisper clean plus system for depletion
of ribosomal rna
we've taken a subset of the samples from
the 60 sample set and we're showing here
a covet negative on the far left moving
up through
the cycle threshold values from 16 to 38
showing a total of seven samples here
you can see that
the nasopharyngeal samples the
the percentage of mapped reads to
ribosomal rna which is shown on the
y-axis here
the percentage map breach varies from
sample to sample but we are very
effectively able to reduce the ribosomal
content from the human
from human ribosomal rna and from
bacterial ribosomal rna
in these samples
so what we're showing in this slide is
our ability to call a cova genome strain
as well as detect the cova genome using
idc and then next strain for the strain
calling
you can see that the samples here that
are in green in the table
these are samples that we have been able
to call the strain and and what we mean
by that is are we calling the strain of
of the cova genome through neck strain
uh far down the clad tree and do the
replicates uh for those samples both or
for the replicates have the same strain
call
showing consistency there and you can
see down to approximately a cycle
threshold of 30
we are getting a confidence strain call
for these samples
next when we think about simply
detecting the covet genome not
necessarily calling the stream but
detecting it and thinking about
detection of infectious diseases in the
future things that we may not know what
the genome sequence is and we're unable
to call a strain but we know enough of
the genome that we can detect it you can
see here that we're able to push the
level of detection down
or push it up to a cycle threshold
around 36. how we define that as
detected and non-strain called is that
each of the replicates may not share the
same strain call or
there's been enough genome sequence for
for idc to assemble contigs of the
genome but there's not enough for next
strain to confidently call that strain
and thus it places it simply on the
trunk of the clayed tree which is the
19a essentially
so here you can see we're able to
with
simple metagen simple metagenomic ngs
shotgun sequencing and the crispr clean
plus
application to drive our cova detection
all the way down to a ct of 36. this is
a very exciting results
as i mentioned earlier this data is also
down sampled to 80 million reads or 40
million clusters and and so
this is a modest amount of sequencing
when thinking about today's cost of
sequencing
next using in-house and custom pipelines
we can look at things like what's the
breadth of coveted
genome coverage or breadth of assembly
that we could derive from our sequencing
data down sample to 80 million reads and
what's the depth of genome coverage and
how is that affected by cycle threshold
so you can see on the left here that
we're seeing 100 genome coverage of the
cova genome um up to about a cycle
threshold of 27 and then we see that
decrease
as we move beyond 27 up to 32 and then
going down below 10 genome coverage as
we move into cycle thresholds of 35 and
higher
of even more interest is our depth of
coverage and and why i mention that is
because of the linearity that we see
of the depth of coverage here uh versus
cycle threshold and thus we in some ways
we have the ability to
pin our average genome coverage uh to a
cycle threshold uh and this is this is
interesting uh for in a number of ways
but um here also just to mention i'm
showing an average of the replicates
here and um
and you can see that even up to um up to
a level of say
33 or 32
cts we're still obtaining greater than
one x depth of coverage across the cova
genome
in the next four slides i'm going to
spend some time showing some data around
composition
this is using our kraken pipeline
as well as some information from idc
as i mentioned earlier
the coveted genome in the study
can be thought of as a proxy as well for
other infectious diseases things that
could be emerging
or things that are already known about
but
understanding what
additional information we can gain
around composition using the crispr
clean plus approach i think is is high
value
and here again we're showing the seven
samples that we've been zooming in on
and ultimately as you can see from the
breadth and depth of coverage graphs i
showed you earlier really representative
of the whole set of samples
but
when we look at something like a mock
sample which essentially has no
depletion
and that goes through a metagenomics
shotgun sequencing approach you can see
here that the bacterial species
identified or anywhere around 2500 to
3500 bacterial species but when we then
apply the depletion approach we can see
that now that we're removing those
ribosomal reeds that were previously
there
because we remove those ribosomal reeds
before they ever make it on a sequencer
we're now then opening up sequencing
real estate to reads that were
previously unsequenced in the mock
samples and now we're driving additional
coverage not only over bacterial species
that we already have seen but also
bacterial species that before were
hidden in the noise and now we're
bringing up
anywhere between you know another
thousand or five hundred fold bacterial
species in this sample this
increases the sensitivity of discovery
and it also increases your ability to
discover
new things about these samples that you
may not have known before things that
could serve as biomarkers or things that
can serve as potential um identification
for co-infections or for other types of
infections
that uh that may not be related to what
this person is actually presenting for
and this slide is showing exactly one of
those samples where we have a a covered
negative patient or sorry a code
somebody that's covered negative and
they're going in to have a test done
because they believe they may have covid
and
we can see from this from the shotgun
sequencing data that this is a
rhinovirus a in this negative sample
it's the highest scoring component in
both replicates from idc
and rhinovirus a is the it's one of the
most common
viral infectious agents in humans and
it's the predominant cause of common
cold so
it could be assumed from this that this
is one of one of the reasons uh that
this person went in to get a cova test
but we were able to detect this and if
um
you know under the state of doing an rt
pcr or even using a a primer set
directed towards covid this is something
that you would not pick up in the sample
and again here's another example we see
that um a co-infection in a
cova-positive sample so this is sample
403
the ct value of this sample was 26.53
showed up as a strong positive
but again in here rhinovirus c
co-infection in both replicates with an
extremely high score from idc and again
cause of common cold this is a
co-infection you can see again
a good breadth and depth of coverage
over the rhinovirus genome here and so
here now we're detecting co-infections
in a cova positive sample
and here we're showing an example that's
a little bit more exploratory
but this sample showed up with a high
score for
this
this virus called
babesiosis
it is a virus that's related to malaria
and um it
has a one to four week incubation period
but the symptoms include fever
general
general feeling of ill health fatigue
and loss of appetite again you can see
down below here in both of the
replicates that we have we have
significant genome coverage shown and uh
and albeit this may not be the reason
that they presented for covet test but
at the same time um this uh shows that
from an exploratory standpoint we're
able to increase discovery in these
types of samples
using the crispr clean plus
approach
so i'm going to spend the next couple
slides talking about host response we
undertook an analysis or transcriptional
analysis of using the human gene content
in these samples something that you
could not do unless you're doing a
shotgun metagenomics approach
but i'm going to talk about
some of the findings from this but
really we wanted to center on our
analysis on can we find pathways that
may be involved in um in the host
response to these infections and so in
that way we were able to analyze covet
negative the 15 cova negative versus a
subset of the of of covet positive
samples
first i wanted to take just a second to
show you the large amount of information
that's been generated around host
response
with regard to covet infection you can
see here these are papers
recent papers you know around the immune
and metabolic signatures of coven 19 and
immune signatures linked to severity
diagnostic host response biosignature
from rna profiling of nasal swabs and
host viral infection maps with
signatures for severity of covet 19.
you know this type of interrogation of
the host response with regards to an
infection
uh obviously has been extremely
important with with regards to kova 19.
but also
it will
continue to be extremely important as we
move forward and we have new strains
come online of influenza or even when we
think about
you know with this data with regards to
the next pandemic
to be able to
take a look at host response and
understand these signatures for the next
pandemic and do it as quickly as
possible
is going to take a shotgun metagenomics
approach and also it's going to take a
methodology
that removes the noise and
makes the signals more clear
and so what we've done here is we took
the 15 coveted negative samples
even though they may have presented with
a cold or other things like that we
still take the covet negative samples
and then we took
the covent positive samples that were
less than a ct of 22 which were 29
samples from those were able to generate
or sorry perform a differential
expression analysis
using degener
from that
we
found a uh signature of a hundred and
around 150 genes uh and then we're able
to look at those genes within
gene ontology pathways and you can see
here on the left the up regulated terms
in the covid positive samples
strongly related to immune system
so we've got t cell chemotaxis
regulation of natural killer cells
macrophage migration macrophage
chemotaxis lymph lymphocyte chemotaxis
this one has a
very very very significant p-value
eosinophil migration eosinophil
chemotaxis all of these movements of
immune cells
migrations and things like that
so we're easily able to identify
with statistical significance
these up regulated
pathways
in the
covid positive samples versus the
coveted negative samples by the way we
did this with no underlying metadata we
did not have any metadata concerning the
severity of the patient's response to
the covid uh in in the positive samples
the severity of the response and we
didn't have any metadata around the
negative samples and in fact as we know
from looking at one of the samples that
has rhinovirus in it that these were not
true negatives that were taking taken
from people that had no symptoms at all
whatsoever yet
still with uh with the lack of meta
information we're still able to find
these these statistically significant
up regulated immune pathways in the
covid positive samples
and so hopefully thus far
the uh presentation has has spurred on
some thoughts about how you might be
able to use um
the jump codes uh solution for your own
research or for other questions and and
certainly we think that way as well in r
d um sometimes good and sometimes bad
but um i'm going to show a couple slides
around other applications we've applied
this to and and these may be things that
you've you've thought about or were
potentially going to ask questions about
so hopefully i can answer some of those
now
so in the crispr clean plus approach we
were using guides designed
against the human
ribosomal non-coding ribosomal rna as
well as the bacterial ribosomal rna and
we want to be depleting those
transcripts but in the case of single
cell and isoseq
because those approaches are poly a
based at least right now
we want to be thinking about the
reduction of of other gene types since
the contribution of of non-coding
ribosomal is very small
and in this case we're really focusing
our attention at least
for some of this initial data on the
mitochondrial coding and ribosomal
coding transcripts and and so for
our single cell set initially we have
what we call our 9010 set you takes the
top 10
coding mitochondrial genes in the top 90
coding ribosomal genes and then we have
guides designed towards those for
depletion
and here we're showing the application
of that 9010 ribomido guide set to uh
coronary artery a single cell sequencing
and pulmonary artery single cell
sequencing on the 10x chromium platform
across multiple patients you can see
here that when
employing these guides for depletion in
these sample types within the 10x
library workflow
that we're we're generating extremely
high rated depletion we're destroying
greater than 90 percent of those
transcripts in there thus opening up
more space um for sequencing of
informative transcripts and uh for the
potential of identifying additional cell
types
we've also applied these guide sets and
methodology to the 10x vision system you
can see here on the left side the tissue
slices or the imaging of the tissue
slices where we have the depleted on the
far left and the control next to that
you can see that as we look down through
the the two mitochondrial genes and the
two
ribosomal genes
that are lighting up in the control
where we're greatly removing those into
the depleted sample
on the right side here and the violin
plots is simply showing the same thing
except in more of a a quantitative way
where you can see that we're
in the in the in the crisper samples uh
the signals from those those transcripts
are completely going away the number of
reads are are completely going away in
those as well
and so you know the depletion of these
targeted regions is significant and the
depletion across samples is significant
and as i mentioned before when we're
removing these transcripts prior to them
going on a sequencer
we then open up that area on the
sequencer to reassign reads that would
have originally gone to these
transcripts or gone to these genes we're
now reassigning those reads to other
genes
that are that are going to be more
informative
and so here we've also taken and applied
this same methodology to um
the uh
iso seek on the pacbio platform using a
10x chromium library system
and
you can see here as we look across these
single cell isoseq samples where we have
sample
a and sample b and we have rpl and rps
which are ribosomal targets
for each of those and then mt which is
our mitochondrial targets for each of
those
that we're uh those originally made up
around 15 percent of all of the data in
these samples and then once we depleted
uh those went down uh to nearly zero um
so freeing up 15 of that data on a pac
bio system for informative reads and you
can see here that
that the depletion has little effect on
on anything library related so the read
link differences between the bulk and
the single cell isoseq actually match
with the library sizes uh pre-sequencing
so there's there's there's no effect
that we're seeing there of the method
i think one of the interesting questions
we can ask is on a pac bio sql 2 system
where you're generating around four
million long read uh zero mode wave
guides
what if we could deplete in such a way
that you could double the usable reads
per flow cell so you
um in this case uh you know we're
freeing up um somewhere around um
you know 600 000 additional reads that
are informative but what if we could
free up two million
additional reads that are informative
and this is something that we're going
after currently and uh and we think we
can do it
and with that i'd like to thank
everybody for their time and attention
today i really appreciate it and i'll
open it up for any questions thank you
again
thank you john for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar joining us today is keith
brown founder and chief technical
officer of jump code genomics
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is can this tech or
method be applied for other infectious
diseases
other than covid
uh yeah the answer is uh yes it's an
agnostic test uh so it doesn't require
any a priori knowledge of what you're
looking for really that's the benefit of
next generation sequencing is that
you'll
at least theoretically interrogate every
molecule in a sample
um the problem with next generation
sequencing is that you interrogate every
molecule in the sample so uh biology
comes in the way an example shown here
was ribosomal sequences and over
abundant housekeeping host transcripts
that don't uh you know provide
informative information for you know
really anything uh including host
response so um yes uh known or unknown
it's uh the concept is
zero day capabilities meaning on day
zero of an outbreak uh can we use this
technology to uh you know identify and
assemble uh
the pathogen genome uh within 48 hours
great thank you
next question
does depletion increase read counts
across other things in the sample in an
even or uneven way
uh in an even way
typically that has to do with the
library construction process itself if
you have a good uh complex library
you've generated
minimizing pcr amplification
you typically see about uh a tenfold
increase at least with um
you know the 13 000 guide sets that were
used in the uh meta transcriptomic study
presented here
um knocking those out uh which is
roughly 90 percent of the reads in the
sample
you get on average a 10-fold increase
across all
non-targeted
species
thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question
does sequencing to greater depth provide
higher sensitivity for variant calling
or covet detection
um so far what we've seen is that it
does not
as john presented here
each sample was down sampled to 40
million clusters or 80 million 2 by 150
paradigm reads
some of the samples were sequenced to
well over
50 60 million clusters or over 100 120
million reads and by adding those
additional reads uh back in
uh what we see is you get a increase in
depth of the same locations
of the cova genome not necessarily an
increase in breath
and what we're looking to determine
right now is
how much additional depletion
gives you an increase in sensitivity not
only to detect but to
cover more of the cover genome and we
hope to publish that data soon
great
well thank you again john and keith for
your time today in your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor jump jumpcode genomics
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye